conjunction junction what's your
function hooking up to boxcars and
making them function it's one of my most
popular song sir conjunction junction in
1971 Bob Dorough oh that's Bob hi
someone asked him let's put the
multiplication tables to rock music and
we'll call it multiplication truck what
do you think
and so this happened schoolhouse rocks
and it ran for 64 episodes songs were
iconic and many of them were written and
performed by Bob oh and I can't say
exactly how many I wrote for school
house Rockwood I'd say about 22 and a
half but Bob's career isn't limited to
School House Rock nope I'm a producer
even an actor
guru sold us out man he tried to hang
that shut up good singer pianist and
all round good guy he played with Miles
Davis deep down he was a sweetheart
Bob's been writing and recording music
for over 50 years
but he agrees that despite all this I'm
probably best known for this job I did
for Schoolhouse Rock it was total fun
when you have a commission that makes it
easier then just to say write me a love
song okay but where do I start but you
know put the multiplication tables to
music and make it interesting 3 6 9 12
15 18 with easy